the diplomatic wheels are still turning
even as vladimir putin's tanks are
rolling closer to kiev
boris johnson was on a tour of eastern
europe to reassure nato allies but for
all the talks he would have had with
fellow leaders today it was an emotional
plea from a ukrainian journalist at a
press conference in poland that cut
straight to the point
you're talking about more sanctions
prime minister but roman abramovich is
not sanctioned he's in london his
children are not in the bombardment his
children are there in london
putin's children are in netherlands
in germany
in mansions where all this mansion
seized i don't see that
i see that my family members that my
team members are saying that we are
crying we don't have had to rob i'm
acutely conscious that there is not
enough that we can do uh to
as the uk government uh to help in the
way that you want the united nations in
geneva was the center for more diplomacy
but not the meeting that many had hoped
for
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken and the russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov were both due to be here
but neither came
lincoln stayed in the united states and
sergey lavrov said that because of the
ban on russian aircraft through european
airspace he was unable to travel
and so in their absence went any hope
that the two men might meet in private
and find some sort of breakthrough
instead the russian foreign minister
gave a televised address and as he did
western diplomats stood up and walked
out and the u.s secretary of state also
speaking remotely suggested russia could
be kicked out of the united nations
human rights council council members
should stop using language implying that
all sides bear equal responsibility for
the unprovoked attack of one side
this isn't even-handed
it's wrong the british foreign secretary
was there in person the blood is on
putin's hands
not just of innocent ukrainians but the
men he has sent to die
he is violating international law
including the un charter and multiple
commitments to peace and security
on an official visit in the uk prince
charles spoke out in defense of
democracy and open society
we are seeing those same values under
attack today
in ukraine
in the most unconscionable way
in the stand we take here we are in
solidarity
with all those who are resisting brutal
aggression
the western unity has been strong and
the sanctions tough there is almost
certainly more to come but whilst it
might have shocked president putin it
hasn't stopped
aleister bunkel sky news geneva